now let's go to the voters in Georgia
that's another key race here the senate
race is so tight in fact many people
expect it could go to a runoff if
neither candidate achieves 50 percent of
the vote and Georgia is where we find
our Nicole Killian today Nicole I feel
like you're going to be tacked paying
taxes in Georgia this year you've been
spending so many weeks there months
really good morning what do you know
oh well what I can tell you Tony is that
the polls just opened here in Atlanta
and you can see lines are already
starting to form the U.S Senate race one
of the Marquee races in this state both
candidates are hoping to avoid a runoff
and secure an outright Victory
Democratic incumbent Senator Rafael
Warnock is spending his day canvassing
and previously told me that he believes
he can win he is no stranger to a runoff
having won in 2021 with Senator John
ossoff who joined him on the trail
Monday Warnock asked supporters for a
full six-year term and argued his GOP
opponent Herschel Walker isn't qualified
for the job but Walker and his team
believe he has a good shot in this race
and say voters want change the former
football star held a rally last night
with South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham and former HUD secretary Dr Ben
Carson Walker did not appear with
Republican Governor Brian Kemp who
headlined an election Eve rally nearby
for the GOP ticket while Democratic
Challenger Stacey Abrams gave a pep talk
to volunt cheers who held a phone and
texting bank now both of these races are
among the most expensive races in the
country with more than
284 million dollars being spent on ads
and the U.S Senate race alone Tony
just a remarkable sum of money in the
cold for us once again in Georgia Nicole
thank you very much